you talk about meeting some of your
heroes so is it true that bob dylan
almost gave you a harmonica and how does
almost happen
yeah i was at the grammys once uh
years ago only once and the grammys is a
crazy award show compared to movie award
shows and musicians
lead very incredible lives
completely inflated if they want to be
and as i'm sure you've
you've seen firsthand on many occasions
if you're a musician you can make it
that you don't interact with one human
being you don't want to which is like
pretty crazy i think and
uh but anyway i was at the grabbies um
and uh bob dylan was there and he
performed and i actually stole a drink
from his dressing room
um but i personally didn't see him um
but
months uh a few months later i was at a
party and a guy i know came up to me and
he told me
um you were at the grammys this year and
i said yes and he goes i was there too
with a friend of mine who actually looks
very much like you and while we were at
the grammys a security guard
came up to him and handed him a
harmonica
and said that bob dylan is a big fan of
yours on howard stern and wanted you to
have this um
and i was like well can i have the
harmonica and um the guy was like
no my friend has kept the harmonica so
and i don't know who this person is
i don't know their name i honestly don't
even remember the friend who is the
mutual person at this point but if you
are watching this and have the harmonic
please just give me the harmonica
i'll maybe they're a musician and they
don't like talking to people says so
you're never going to see it
maybe they're all completely insulated
from society and we'll never see this
shape you need to go
to a country award show because i did
grow up with pop award shows in the
finish that is probably
very different country award shows are
very different everyone's door is open
they actually share dressing rooms it's
a different experience yep i'm still
here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever